The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK, so basically
probability ideas today,
because that's a part of the
subject, part of deep learning
as we get there.
And it's probably a
good topic for the day
before spring break, because
lots of you will have seen--
of course, you will
have seen the sample
mean, the average of the data.
And you'll know about
the expected mean.
Let me complete that.
What's the expected mean?
So this is the
expectation of the value x
where we get x1
with probability P1
along to xn with probability Pn.
So we just want to say,
what's our average output--
average outcome?
And we weight it by
their probabilities.
So it's P1 x1 plus
so on plus Pn xn.
So that's the
expected value of x.
Are you comfortable
with that symbol E?
Because that's like everywhere.
It gives a handy shorthand.
For example, the variance is
the expected value of what?
The variance is
an expected value
based on these probabilities
of the square of the distance.
So everybody remembers
it involves square.
And it's the distance
from the mean.
Let me call this, say, m, maybe,
just to have a smaller letter.
So it's the distance
from the mean minus m.
It's the expected value, the
average value of x minus m
squared.
And in general, of
course, the expected--
this covariance matrix I could
express with that E notation.
But let me just
stretch it as far as
what would be the expected
value of any function of x?
Well, we've got n possible
outputs, x1 to xn.
We look at f of
x1 up to f of xn.
We weight those by the
probabilities that they happen.
So this would be--
let me make just a little
corner for this E letter--
so this would be the
probability that that
is f of x1 times the
value of f of x1.
So this is the contribution
from the x1 possibility.
And now, we include them all.
So it will be output f of
xn with probability Pn.
And if that f of x
is x minus m squared,
then we get what we expect.
And let me remember that.
So I just want to keep
going with variance.
So it's the sum.
It's the first probability times
the first output minus the mean
squared the last probability
times that last output
xn minus m squared.
And everybody should
know a second expression,
a second way, to
do that the sum.
If I just write
out those squares
and combine them a
little differently,
I get a second expression
which is really useful, often
a little faster to compute.
So can I just do that?
So that's x1 squared minus
2 x1 m1 plus m1 squared.
And then same thing
here, Pn times xn
squared minus 2xn
m plus m squared.
Good with that?
AUDIENCE: On that m--
GILBERT STRANG: Sorry?
GILBERT STRANG:
Plus n, oh, sorry.
No, I mean-- am I--
AUDIENCE: So for P1
it's x1 squared minus--
GILBERT STRANG:
Oh, it's just an m.
Correct.
Thank you.
Just an m.
Good.
OK.
Can we take that sum?
So I get P1 x1 squared if I
take these, the first guys.
So I've accounted
for this and this.
Now, I'll take minus 2 P1 x1 m.
So P1 x1 m plus Pn xn m.
I'm just writing it all out,
and I'm going to recombine it.
So now, I have P1 m squared plus
P2 m squared plus Pn m squared.
So what do I have
from the P1 m squared
all the way up to Pn m squared?
Are you with me?
So m squared is in every term.
So I'm going to
have an m squared.
And what's it multiplied by?
P1 here, P2 here, Pn here.
I add those up and I get?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1.
So that's it.
OK, now, I'll just
simplify this thing.
So this is really the
expected value of what?
What am I seeing in this term?
AUDIENCE: x squared.
GILBERT STRANG: The expected
value of x squared, right.
Different from the
expected value of x minus m
squared, of course.
This is just a first
term from here.
But, now, what do I get
for this second term?
Well, the point is
that m comes out.
So this is minus an m and a 2.
And what do I have left?
So I've used up the m.
I've used up the 2.
P1 x1 dot dot dot
Pn xn, what's that?
Everybody should just
pay attention to this.
Trivial, I mean, we're just
doing high school algebra here.
But P1 x1 up to Pn xn is m.
So I have another
m, m squared there.
And I have a plus m
squared from the n.
So you see that it is another
expression, the expected value
of x squared minus m squared.
It's just algebra.
That is the same as this.
So that if you happen
to have a handy way
to compute the expected
value of x squared,
you would just
subtract m squared.
And you'd have the same as this.
Yeah, it's just algebra.
OK, let's go a little
deeper with something here--
if I can find it.
There are two great
inequalities in statistics.
And the first one
is due to Markov.
And I don't know if you
know Markov's inequality.
It comes out easily,
in fact, too easily.
I'm kind of happy
to discuss him.
And now I've jumped to
Section 5 of the book.
So I'll need to post
Section 5, which
is probability and statistics.
And you'll see this
Markov inequality.
So it just involves this stuff.
So that's why I'll go do it now.
Markov's inequality.
He was a great
Russian mathematician,
oh, probably about 1900.
And we will see Markov
chains and Markov processes,
that's beautiful linear algebra.
But this little inequality
is not matrices.
It's just playing with these.
And it applies to
non-negative events.
So shall I say applies when
all the x, all the outputs,
are greater than
or equal to zero.
So I'm going to use that fact.
So it doesn't apply to
something like a Gaussian,
because there, the
Gaussian, the outputs
go all the way from minus
infinity to infinity.
It does apply to a lot of
important ones and simple ones.
I'll give you the proof for
this finite probability.
And there will be a similar
proof, similar discussion
everywhere here for
continuous probability.
So what does Markov say?
Let me be sure I get it right,
because I'm not a pro at this.
It's natural to want to
estimate the probability that x
is greater or equal
to some number a.
Get some idea of what's
the probability of x
being greater or equal to a.
So what do we know?
This is certainly a
number between 0 and 1.
That number is going to
get smaller as a increases,
because we're going
to be asking for more.
If I take a to b,
say, twice the mean,
can I estimate what that
probability could be.
And that's what Markov has done.
He says the probability
of that is at least--
at most-- sorry.
Let's see I used
to have an eraser--
at least-- sorry, at most--
yes, got it, got it--
is less or equal to the mean--
x bar is another way
to write the mean--
divided by a.
And this is the
mean over a or it's
the expected value of x over a.
We could see any
of those notations.
OK.
And as we expect, as a
increases, the probability,
this number, goes
down, the probability
goes down of exceeding a.
So that's a pretty
simple estimate
to get this probability
just in terms of the number
a, which has to come in, because
it's part of the question,
and the mean, x.
So let me take an
example as a equals 3.
For example, suppose a with 3.
I want to show that the
probability of x being greater
than or equal to 3.
Yeah, OK.
We don't have many
facts to work with.
So if we write those down,
we should see the reason.
So I know that the
mean is E of x.
So let's see, am
I going to take--
yeah, for example, let's
take the mean to be 1.
So I'm going to imagine
that the mean is 1
and that I'm asking for
what's the chance that x
will be bigger than 3.
And I'll get an estimate of 1/3.
So I'm trying to show
that the probability of x
greater or equal 3
is less or equal to--
the mean, I'm saying is 1.
a is 3.
So it is less than or equal 1/3.
Now, why is that true?
That's what I have to show.
I think that if I write down
what I know, I'll see it.
So let me just raise that a
little so that I have room
to write.
So what do I know?
I know the definition
of the mean.
So I know that x1 times
P1 plus x2 P2 plus x3 P3--
allow me to get
carried away here--
x5 P5, say, is what?
So what I've written
down there is the mean.
And I'm assuming that to be 1.
So this is the fact
that I know is 1.
And what is it that
I want to prove?
I want to know the probability
of being greater or equal 3.
So what's the probability
that the result
will be greater or equal 3?
It's P3.
So this is saying
that P3 plus P4--
these are the probabilities.
These are the
different ways that I
might be greater or equal 3.
And I'm claiming that that's
less than or equal 1/3.
What I liked about this
elementary approach
is that I've stated these
facts, these probability
assumptions and conclusions
directly in terms of numbers.
So I just want to show that if
this is true, then that's true.
Let's see, I guess I'm
thinking that the--
I'm sorry, I even took
a more special case.
I'm taking the case where x1 is
1, x2 is 2, x3 is 3, x4 is 4,
and x5 is 5.
So that satisfies my
condition that the outputs--
1, 2, 3, 4, or 5--
are all-- Markov
only applies when
they're all greater or equal 0.
So I'm just imagining
the special case
where that possible
outputs are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Their probabilities
are P1, P2, P3, P4, P5.
The mean is 1.
And what I want to show
is that the probability
of being greater than 3
is less than or equal 1/3.
And can you put
together these two?
Given this, we want
to conclude that.
Let me just step back a minute.
So what do we know here?
We know this, the first line.
And we want to prove the second.
We know one more thing.
All the probability-- well,
we know the probabilities
add to 1.
And we know they're
all greater equal 0.
So let me put those
facts in here too.
We know that P1 plus P2 plus
P3 plus P4 plus P5 is 1.
That we know.
And we also know
that all the P's
are greater than or equal to 0.
OK.
So here we go.
My idea is this is looking at
3 times P3 plus P4 plus P5.
So I'm going to take 3 P3
plus 3 P4 away from this.
So this we'll say P1 plus 2 P2
plus 3 of P3 plus P4 plus P5.
I'm just picking out
three of those guys.
Plus I have one more
P4 to account for
and two more P5s gives 1.
Good?
Now, this is what
I'm trying to prove.
So that is here.
I'm trying to prove
that this thing is--
what am I trying to
prove about that number?
Sorry, I'm talking a lot.
But now, I've really
come to the point.
What is Markov telling
me about that number?
That's--
AUDIENCE: Less
than or equal to 1.
GILBERT STRANG: That is
less than or equal to?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: Thanks.
OK, I'm trying to prove that
this is less than or equal 1.
That's what Markov tells me.
But suppose it was
greater than 1?
Do you see the problem?
Do you see why it can't
be greater than 1?
Because why?
AUDIENCE: All are
the other terms--
GILBERT STRANG: All the other
terms are greater equal 0.
Probabilities or
greater equal 0.
These are all greater equal 0.
And the total things adds to 1.
So that this piece has
to be less or equal to 1.
That's right.
That's it.
So a lot of talking there.
Simple idea.
And you'll see exactly
this example written down
in the notes.
And then you'll see a
more conventional proof
of Markov's inequality by
taking simple inequality steps.
But they're somehow
more mysterious.
For me, this was explicit.
OK, so that's Markov.
Chebyshev is the other
great Russian probabilist
of the time.
And he gets his inequality.
So there are the two.
There's Markov's equality.
Let me write it down
again what it was.
Here was Markov's inequality
and Markov's assumption.
Chebyshev doesn't
make that assumption.
So now, no assumption of
that the outputs are greater
equal 0.
Doesn't come in.
Now what is Chebyshev
trying to estimate?
OK, let's move to Chebyshev.
And that's the last guy.
So Chebyshev was interested in
the probability that x minus
the mean, m-- can I
use that for mean--
is probably greater equal to a--
the probability of being sort
of a distance a away from mean.
So again, as a increases,
I'm asking more,
I'm asking it to be
further away from the mean,
and the probability will drop.
And then the question
is can we estimate this?
So this is a different estimate.
But it's similar question.
And what Chebyshev's
answer for this?
So this is the
probability of this.
I have to put off big--
that's all one mouthful--
the probability that this x
minus m is greater equal to a.
And again, we're going
to have is less than
or equal to sigma squared
now comes in over a squared.
So that's Chebyshev.
And I just take time
today to do these two
because they involve analysis.
They're basic tools.
They're sort of
the first thing you
think of if you're trying
to estimate a probability.
Does it fit Markov?
And Markov only applies--
so I'll put only applies--
when the x's are all
greater or equal 0.
Here, does it fit Chebyshev?
And now we're taking
absolute values.
So we're not concerned
about the size of x.
And we're taking
a distance from m.
So we're obviously in
the world of variances.
We're distances from m.
And the proof of Chebyshev
comes directly from Markov.
So I'm going to apply Markov--
so good thing that
Markov came first--
to-- now let me just
say this right--
to a new, let me call it, y--
this will be a new output.
And it will be x
minus m squared.
Of course, with the
same probability.
So yi is xi minus m,
the mean, squared.
And the same probability,
same probabilities Pi.
So I guess if I'm
going to apply--
I'm just going to take the y's
here instead of the x's here
and then apply Markov.
So what is x bar?
So if I want to
apply Markov, I have
to figure out the mean of x.
Over here, I have to
figure out the mean of y.
What is the mean of y?
The mean value, the sum of
probabilities times y's.
You're supposed to recognize it.
This is the sum
of probabilities.
And my y's are the xi
minus the mean squared.
So this is the mean
for this y thing
that I've brought
in has that formula.
And we recognize what
that quantity is.
That is?
That's sigma squared, sigma
squared for the original x's.
So that's great.
So the mean is sigma--
is the old sigma squared.
Those are exclamation marks.
Do see that now Chebyshev
is looking like Markov?
Over here will be the x--
now I want the expected
value of y over the--
let's see, yeah, so the
expected y is going to be that.
And now what do I
have to divide by?
I want to know probability of
this thing being bigger than a.
But now I'm looking at the y's.
So the probability
of if x minus m
is greater than or equal to a,
then x minus xi minus m squared
is greater equal a squared.
So my a over here
for x is now turning,
in this problem
where I'm looking
at probability greater
equal a but squaring it,
this is the a squared.
So that's Markov applied to y.
Here is Markov applied to x.
And x had to be greater equal 0.
So over here, Chebyshev took a
y, which was greater equal to 0
than just applied
Markov and recognize
that mean of his variable,
x minus m squared
was exactly sigma squared.
And it fell out.
So again, here is a very
simple proof for Markov.
And then everybody agrees that
Chebyshev follows right away
from Markov.
So those are two
basic inequalities.
Now, the other topic that
I wanted to deal with
was covariance,
covariance matrix.
You have to get comfortable
with what's the covariance.
So covariance,
covariance matrix,
and it will be m by m when I
have m experiments at once.
And let me take m equal to 2.
You'll see everything
for m equal to 2.
So we're expecting to
get a 2 by 2 matrix.
And what are we starting with?
We start we're doing
two experiments at once.
So we have two
outputs, an x and a y.
So the x's are the outputs
from the x experiment.
The y's are the output
from a second experiment.
We're flipping two coins.
So let's take that
example, two coins.
Coin 1 gets 0 or 1 with P
equal to the probability 1/2.
Coin 2, 0 or 1 with
probability 1/2.
So they're fair coins.
But what I haven't said
is, is there a connection
between the output--
this is the x.
This is the y--
if I glue the coins together,
then the two outputs
are the same.
I think for me this is a
model question that brings out
the main point of covariance.
If I flipped two
coins separately,
quite independently, then
I don't know more about y
from knowing x.
If I know the
answer to one flip,
it doesn't tell me
anything about the second
if they're independent,
uncorrelated.
But if the two coins
are glued together,
then heads will come
up for both coins.
I'll only have
two possibilities.
It'll be heads heads
or tails tails.
Let me let me write down
those two different scenarios.
So unglued-- I never expected
to write that word in a math
class--
unglued.
And what am I going
to write down?
I'm going to write down a matrix
with heads, tails for coin 1,
and heads and tails for coin 2.
So the possibilities are
coin one get heads and coin 2
gets heads.
What's the probability of that?
This is the unglued case.
So I'm going to create
a little probability
matrix of joint probabilities.
That's really the key word
that I'm discussing here--
joint probability.
So let's complete that matrix.
So I have unglued coins,
independent coins.
I flip them both.
What is the chances of
getting heads on both?
1/4.
What are the chances of--
what do I put in here?
This means heads
on the first coin
and tails on this second coin.
And the probability of that is?
1/4.
And 1/4 here and 1/4 here.
So I've got four possibilities,
which I put into a 2
by 2 matrix, instead
of a long vector.
My four possibilities are
heads heads, heads tails,
tails heads, and tails tails.
And they have
equal probability--
1/4.
But now, if they're glued, heads
and tails on the first coin,
heads and tails on the
second coin, now what do I
put in there?
So the two coins
are glued together.
What is the chance that
they both come up heads?
1/2.
Because if one comes up heads,
the other one is glued to it.
It will also.
What's the probability of heads
tails, heads on one, tails
on the other, is of course?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
GILBERT STRANG: Zero, thanks.
And here, zero.
And here, 1/2.
So what I've created
are those two setups,
two different scenarios
of unglued and glued.
But each experimental
setup has its matrix
of joint probabilities.
That's the thing that there
are four numbers here,
four numbers.
We have all possibilities.
We have any possible x and at
the same time any possible y.
So suppose we were
running three experiments.
So what would be the what
would be the situation if I
was running three
experiments with three
independent, fair coins.
I'd be in this unglued picture.
But I would have three different
experiments that I'm running.
Then what would I
be looking at then?
Just the whole
idea is to see what
is this like joint probability.
So suppose I have
three coins unglued.
Then I want to know like the
probability of getting heads
on the first, heads on the
second, heads on the third.
Will be what?
Just give me that number.
What will be the probability
that all three of them
independently come up heads?
AUDIENCE: 1/8.
GILBERT STRANG: 1/8, OK.
But now my question is--
so what do I have?
Then I have
probability of heads,
of, say, tails heads heads.
I've got three indices
here and eventually
down the probability
of tails tails tails.
Everybody sees that the
numbers are going to be 1/8.
But where do those fit in?
They don't fit in a
matrix, because I've
got 3 indices here.
So I guess what we're seeing,
I sort of realized today,
we're seeing for the
first time a tensor.
A tensor is a
three-way structure,
three-way matrix you could say.
So I guess I think of this
instead of a square like that,
an ordinary matrix, I have
to think of a cube, right?
I have a cube with two rows,
two columns, and two whatevers.
Layer, somebody might
say layers for that.
You see that the
matrix has become
a three-way thing, a tensor.
And the entries in that tensor--
so it's 2 by 2 by 2.
But instead of m
by n for a matrix,
I have to give you the number
of rows, the number of columns,
and the number of layers
going into the board.
So rows going one way--
you know, columns, rows, and
then layers are going in deep.
So it will have eight entries.
And, of course, in
this simple case
each will be 1/8 in that
unglued, totally independent
way.
But then you can
imagine some dependence.
So what would happen if
I glued coins 1 and 3?
I would still have a
tensor, still have a 2 by 2
by 2 tensor of all
the possibilities.
But some of those are
going to have probability
zero, the joint probability.
If I've glued coin 1 to coin 3,
then the probability of jointly
seeing heads on one,
whatever on two, tails on 3
will be 0, right?
Because that can't happen
if I've glued coins 1 and 3.
So I'll have eight
entries in here.
This is the unglued case.
And then I could have a case
where two coins are glued.
And as I say, I think I'd
1/4 four times probably.
And then if I had any spare
glue, I glue all three coins.
I flip that stuck
together thing,
and I never get
heads tails heads.
Only possibilities
I get our heads
heads heads and
tails, tails, tails,
because they're glued together.
So what would be the situation
for three coins glued?
What will be the entries
in the in the matrix
of joint probabilities?
What will be the
joint probability?
So the probability of heads
heads heads, of seeing heads
from all three will be?
AUDIENCE: 1/2.
GILBERT STRANG: 1/2.
1/2.
Because I'm flipping this heavy
mix of three coins together,
I get 1/2 twice.
Actually, this is a good
introduction to tensors
in a way, because the first
step in understanding tensor
is to think of
three-way matrices,
think of three-way things.
We just haven't done that.
And now we have to do it.
And, of course, four-way
or n-way tensors
are now understood.
So these are tensors with
very special, simple things.
So now, I have to say, what
is the covariance matrix?
What's the covariance matrix?
So now I'm ready for that,
and I'll put it here.
That's the final
topic for today.
So the covariance matrix.
So I'm saying matrix, because
I'm just going to have--
yeah, the covariance matrix.
Yeah, it's going to be
2 by 2 for two coins.
So it is a matrix.
For three coins,
it will be 3 by 3.
But it is a matrix.
So how is it defined?
And what am I going to call it?
I think I'll call v, because
really the key ideas variance.
Covariance is telling
us that we're also
interested in the joint
outcome, an x and y.
So it's a variance.
So I'm going to add up over
all plausible i and j--
sorry, all possible outcomes.
Yeah, that's not right.
All possible xi and yj.
So I'm running these two
experiments at the same time.
From experiment 1,
the output's an x.
From experiment 2,
the output's a y.
Then what is Pij?
What does that symbol mean?
That's the guy in
our 2 by 2 matrix,
like that one or that one,
depending on the gluing
or not gluing.
So Pij, let me say what it is.
This is the probability
that x is xi
and that the second
output that this is yj.
Let me give you a second
example to keep in mind.
Suppose I'm looking
at age and height.
So suppose x is the age
of the sample, the person.
And y is the height.
I want to know so what
fraction have a certain age
and a certain height.
I'm looking at every
pair, age and height.
Age 11, height 4 feet.
Age 12, height 5 feet.
Age 11, height 5 feet.
Each combination.
So Pij is the probability that
these will both happen, both.
I'm going to add
more to it here.
But that joint probability
is really important.
So I'm going to ask
you more about that.
Suppose that I take these
Pijs and that I add up
P1j plus P2j plus P3j.
In other words, I
sum the Pijs over i.
So I'm looking at a row,
row i, of my matrix.
So let me ask the question.
Maybe I have to put
it somewhere else.
What's the meaning of the
sum of Pij over the i's?
What does that
quantity look like?
So that's a probability.
Pij is the
probability of getting
a certain i and a certain j.
But now I'm including
all the i's.
So what am I seeing there?
AUDIENCE: Pj.
GILBERT STRANG: Pj.
Thanks.
Pj.
This is Pj.
That's the probability of
seeing j in the second guy,
because I had to see something.
If I see j in the
second one, I'm
allowed to see anything
here in the first one.
But I'm adding those all up.
So that's the point.
Those would be
called the marginals.
In my matrices, I would
be adding up along a row
or adding up down my column.
Those are called the marginals
of the joint probabilities.
So the marginals would be
the individual probabilities,
Pi and Pj, in the case of
two experiments going on
at the same time.
Yeah, it's just like new ideas.
Everything today has been
sort of straightforward.
But it's different.
OK, now, I'm going to
complete the definition
of this covariance matrix.
So it's going to be--
I want to have a square.
and it should be this is
between x and the mean of x.
Mean 1 I could call
it or mean of x.
And y, the distance from
the mean of y times--
so it's going to be
column times row--
same x minus the mean of
x, y minus the mean of y.
xi.
yj.
Can you look at this formula?
So this is with two experiments,
two coins, two experiments.
I get a 2 by 2 matrix.
Everybody sees that.
A column times a
row, 2 by 2 matrix.
And let's just see what would be
the 1, 1 entry in that matrix.
This is the covariance matrix.
So what is the 1, 1
entry in that matrix?
So the 1, 1 entry
is coming from that
times that, which is that thing
squared, times all the Pijs.
Add them up.
What do you think
I get for that?
I get the variance
of the x experiment,
the standard variance of
the x experiment, so v--
I have to tell
you what v is now.
V, this is V. This
is a 2 by 2 matrix.
Up here, I get the variance
of the x experiment.
What do I get down here?
The variance of the y
experiment by itself.
Because it's y's times y's,
it gives me that 2, 2 entry.
So this is just sigma y squared,
But the novelty is the 1,
2, and it will be symmetric.
So it's a symmetric matrix.
This is V transpose.
I just have to see here.
So I've Pij times the distance
of this guy times this guy.
That's what's going to show
up in the 1, 2 position.
It'll be in row 1.
It'll be in column 2.
It's the distances.
So what will it be in the
case of unglued coins,
independent coins?
Zero.
I mean, it's just
feeling like 0.
I haven't done the computation.
But I know that when I have
independent experiments, then
this covariance, which everybody
would write as sigma xy--
and it's the same here.
It's symmetric,
sigma yx if you like.
So those subscripts
are telling me
that the sum of the P's,
joint probabilities,
times the distance
of x from its means,
the distance of y from
its main, added up
over all the possibilities.
So the case of unglued coins,
the case of independent ones,
in that case, those are 0.
Maybe worth just
writing that out.
You would get 0.
So you have a diagonal matrix.
The diagonal matrix is
just separate variances,
because that's all the two
independent-- the experiments
are independent.
So all you can really expect--
information is sigma x
squared and sigma y squared.
But if the two coins are
glued together, then what?
If the two coins
are glued together--
well, let me just say
because time is up.
This matrix will be singular.
If the two coins
were glued together,
the determinant would be 0 here.
The sigma xy in the
glued case would be--
squared-- would be the same
as sigma x squared sigma
y squared.
Actually, we're probably
getting all these 1/4s.
And that would make sense.
I'll just end with
this statement.
This matrix is positive
semidefinite always.
Positive semidefinite always.
Because it's column
times row, we
know that's positive
semidefinite.
And it's multiplied by
numbers greater or equal 0.
So it's a combination of rank 1
positive semidefinite definite.
So it's positive
semidefinite definite.
Or positive definite.
It's certainly positive
definite in the independent case
when it's diagonal.
And the totally dependent case,
when the coins are completely
stuck together, that will
be the semidefinite case
when these entries would
all be the same actually.
So that's a first look
at covariance matrices.
It brought in tensors.
It brought in joint
probabilities.
It brought in column times row.
It kept symmetry.
And we recognized positive
definite or positive
semidefinite definite.
So in between, coins
that were partly glued,
partly independent, but
not completely independent
experiments, then this
number would be smaller.
This wouldn't be 0, but it would
be smaller than these numbers.
I've run four minutes over.
You're very kind to stay.
So have a wonderful break.
And I'll see you a
week from Monday.
Good.
Thanks.